how are you keeping up how's i mean how
has been self-isolation been treating
you
self-isolation has been pretty good i'm
with my brother so i get some
interaction every now and then but
pretty much we stay to ourselves i've
pretty much organized the entire house
cleaned out my garage
every single junk jar is now an
organized piece masterpiece
um keep it busy you know what i mean
are you the kind of person that has a
hard time like keeping still is that
what that's about
not at all actually for the first two
weeks of quarantine i was
still really and then when they
elongated it i said oh
okay well now that i have some time i
don't have to worry about going to work
right now
let me dig into this so and then i still
take my breaks i don't go
all day but i'll go a good six hours and
then i'll rest for the rest of the day
so
have you done any self-reflection have
you learned anything new about yourself
in this time
i've learned a lot of stuff about myself
um stuff that i'm willing to tell stuff
that i'm willing not to tell
but mostly that i
i i have to grow up i think we all have
that moment in our brain when we're like
14 15 13 and
i'm stuck there a little bit obvious
reasons
but uh with this corona and being by
myself and
not able to call anyone for any kind of
help well
except for my mom she's awesome and
you're there but it's it's interesting
how much you have to grow up in these
times
yeah yeah a lot of people are excited
that um that the show is coming back for
another season i mean we're almost
wrapping up
season three getting close there do you
think raven could have
ever predicted anything like this
happening in 2020
i mean i'm gonna toot her own horn but
no i don't think so this is this
definitely blindsided us for sure
yeah um has it been what's it been like
for you i'm sure
interesting but also it probably must be
satisfying to see this character
continue and continue
i mean we got introduced for such a long
time ago
and you've got fans that have stayed
with you all this time up until
you know now nearing the end of season
three of ravenstone of the new of the
new show
yeah it feels it um it's it's it's
it's both it's weird it's great it's
like are you serious this is cool what's
happening
it's a lot of emotions built into one
show which
i think that's why a lot of people can
connect to it because
you know you have the parents who watch
you have almost the grandparents who
watch me on cosby
you have the parents who watch me on
either cooper that's a raven
and now you have the kids watching it so
you can all come together and
have a freak out time lapse
of all the generations that raven baxter
or myself have been a part of and you
just enjoy television so it's pretty
cool
yeah people can do a very significant uh
binge watch
of like everything raven's ever been a
part of anything that you've ever been a
part of right
and thanks to disney channel i mean
thanks to disney plus and uh
netflix you really can now and hulu yeah
um what can we look forward to in the
upcoming season the new season
the kids are growing up raven and
chelsea are really buckling down on
their jobs um
and you know more topics that are
current for today
wonderful about third season we did a
great vaping episode and more to come
the kids are going to high school
so seeing how the mothers deal with that
you know because i think i'm 13 so i'm
like what
you're not in high school which i'm not
um but yeah
seeing how life evolves i love fourth
season it's it was it was
fun to do we had to stop for corona but
it's been fun to do so far
yeah um you know i've talked to actors
before who said
that they've learned a lot through their
characters about themselves or how they
can interact
with the world through their characters
and we've seen
raven be young and we've seen her be
you know a single mom as well when you
look at
the actors that you're working with the
young actors and they're growing up and
and getting older what do you say to
them with regards to
how to continue on in this industry how
to be happy with themselves and with the
work that they do
to stay professional i think i look at
what i do
as a legit job and not necessarily my
entire lifestyle yes
i blurred those lines every now and then
depending on what's happening but
i just let them know like this is a job
everyone's here for a reason
and then you can go have fun later and
celebrate who you are and what you've
done later but while you're at work it's
really important to keep your ego in
check
and to remember that we're all here
because someone hired us to be here
and um i tell them that i tell them you
know have fun make sure you say no
it sounds like i'm a negative nancy but
i'm not but make sure you say no because
so when you're in that position so many
things are offered to you
you can get tired because you feel like
this opportunity will never come again
you have to have faith in your talent
and who you are so you can say no every
now and then
save your energy but also make sure you
say yes
to balance out so that you still stay in
that bracket
persons i think noah is one of those
words that
as you mature you learn that it you find
your own power in it
right when you feel like you don't have
to accept things just because they're
coming your way and you said before that
that was a big turning point for you a
few years ago
is that one of the things that led you
to take a break finding your own power
and being able to say no what was that
about
yeah most definitely i needed to leave i
had been in the industry for a really
really long time nothing had changed in
my eyes and my world everybody was
enjoying what i was producing but i
myself felt no growth
and i felt like at goodness gracious
that was uh right after that was right
after a sister act i don't know what
year that was
2012 some of i don't know anyway not
recent
and um after that i just looked at my
manager and my mom and everybody
involved in my career oh
hi sorry about that that's pretty much
what i did
that's pretty much what i did know my my
uh gimbal just ran out of power so we're
just gonna shut that off
um but yeah i went to them i said listen
i've i got money
i need a break like i need to go
away i need to make sure that since i
was three years old to 20 something
that this is the right decision i'm a
little late in choosing that but i was
busy and i couldn't you know i didn't
plan anything and it was
probably
and something i probably need to do like
once every five years is just take
a few months off because it really does
help to rejuvenate you
i know with corona there's so many
negatives going on there's so many sad
moments but
for those who are not
in that sad state there is a chance for
change right now
and that's what i'm going through and it
and it's kind of how i felt when i said
no to the industry like let me get my
life together
let me get myself in order without
distractions
and go about my business and i feel like
that's what's happening right now and
what happened then
you know we just joked a couple times
about being like 13 like forever
13 years old and you know that can sound
a bit self-deprecating but there really
is
uh also joy and a bit of power in being
able to stay young as well do you think
that that's
an important thing to be able to
maintain as you grow and
find that balance i guess when i find a
balance right now i'm just like
what what yeah i know i got houses
but i i'm an adult um yeah i guess it is
i'll i'll find
it when i get there but right now i'm
like act like an adult
who is driving uh the other person more
crazy in that house you were your
brother
oh the dogs are driving um
i think we're driving the dogs crazy
okay
because we're not i'm i'm always moving
around the house keeping my mind busy my
brother's playing video games he's in uh
online tournaments and my brothers and
my dogs are like
are you serious dude can we just like go
for a walk i'm like you got it outside
though
so we'll see what happens um
before we go is there anything you want
to say to uh the frontline workers the
people out there that are
you know sacrificing their time
sacrificing their health to keep
our entire world going thank you
to everyone out there that are in these
essential jobs
that are making our world uh run still
during this
crazy time in our history thank you
appreciated into all the small
businesses
no i'm helping you out i'm you'll always
find me in a small place
um we love you thank you so much and
hopefully you get your check soon
right on thank you so much for your time
thank you have a great day
you